Traduttore: Chiara Grottini
Revisore: Veronica Giordani
Buonasera a tutti,
io inizio con il dirvi che sono
qui grazie a
a due persone, che hanno trasferito
tutta la loro personalità
tutta la loro ricchezza interiore
a me.
E quindi sono qui innanzitutto
per testimoniare
come la storia personale di una persona
sia la storia di altre persone,
anche di altre persone,
oltre che la propria.
Mi riferisco a mio nonno,
che faceva l'agricoltore qui in Umbria,
e mi riferisco a mio fratello,
ragazzo autistico di 28 anni.
L'agricoltura sociale quindi,
partiamo dal che cos'è.
E' un meccanismo di governance
in cui le aziende agricole profit,
quindi tradizionali, diversificano
la propria attività storica
implementando servizi socio-sanitari.
Parallelamente, tutto questo è avvenuto
nella realtà già da alcuni anni,
la cooperazione sociale, quindi
le realtà imprenditoriali non-profit,
hanno iniziato spontaneamente a
convergere verso le zone rurali
perchè il verde cura, perchè in mezzo
ad un bosco stiamo meglio tutti
semplificando al massimo.
Da questa conversione nasce appunto
un ibrido,
un innesto, per usare un termine
da agricoltura appunto,
in cui due forme societarie
tradizionalmente distanti,
si incontrano e nasce una forma di
impresa agricola - sociale.
Guardiamo un attimo come
come operano, come si opera
in agricoltura sociale
Sostanzialmente, attraverso un
processo di democrazia partecipativa
molto paritaria,molto trasversale,
e attraverso i principi
della sussidiarietà,
quindi prendendo su se stessi
l'iniziativa per realizzare ciò che manca
quindi abbandonando un po'
la classica ottica assistenziale,
questi attori prototipano e gestiscono
diversificazione aziendale,
assistenza terapeutica,
e andando oltre un meccanismo
che riqualifica le comunità stesse
Quindi, comunità che si uniscono,
lavorano,
lavorano per chi? Per loro stesse.
Perché? Perché l'agricoltura sociale?
Perché innanzitutto, c'è
bisogno di sostenibilità ambientale.
Spesso, queste aziende producono,
quasi sempre, in regime
di agricoltura biologica,
sono OGM free,
e fanno una vera e propria
tutela del territorio
e sappiamo che,
con il rischio idrogeologico
che abbiamo nel nostro Paese,
la sola presenza in certe zone
di certi attori
garantisce la sostenibilità, proprio
territoriale ed ambientale.
C'è una spiccata multifunzionalità
in agricoltura sociale.
Mi riferisco al contadino
che sta dimostrando
come dalla semplice coltura
della ben nota zucchina,
si possa passare a produzioni di energia,
produzioni di servizi turistici,
produzioni di servizi educativi,
pensiamo alle fattorie didattiche,
e all'ultimo, di recente,
in ordine temporale,
ai servizi socio-sanitari.
Abbiamo uno spettro di servizi
che possono essere
realizzati in campagna impressionante.
Andiamo dal agri-asilo e agri-nido,
in cui ci sono i bambini,
a la casa per la terza età,
per rappresentare lo spettro
attraverso un arco temporale.
E la multifunzionalità non è soltanto
operativa in senso economico,
ma lo è anche da un punto di vista
di inserimento lavorativo.
Quindi, sappiamo che
un soggetto con particolare svantaggio
può passare tranquillamente
in un'azienda agricola
per trovare la propria posizione
da la semina, piuttosto che
il servizio al coperto
in un back office amministrativo
di un agriturismo,
alla sgranatura dei legumi,
e tante altre cose.
Quindi, multifunzionale nel mercato,
multifunzionale nelle mansioni interne.
C'è un welfare partecipativo.
Io posso testimoniarvi, grazie alla
esperienza diretta che poi vi racconterò,
che non c'è servizio
all'interno del contesto rurale
che non venga negoziato per così dire
da tutti i portatori di interesse.
c'è un approccio multistakeholder
Cioè se si deve parlare di come assistere
la persona autistica,
la persona autistica è la prima
ad essere tenuta in considerazione
e andando avanti
nelle varie sfaccettature
professionali e umane,
che si incontrano all'interno
di questa realtà,
la voce conta e le voci di tutti contano.
Vengono tutelati i beni comuni
all'interno dell'agricoltura sociale:
acqua, terra, fossi,
zone montane, zone periurbane, aria
pensiamo a tutto quello che è l'insieme
anche dei mezzi,
anche degli immobili che troviamo
in agricoltura,
che purtroppo con l'abbandono
di certe zone
era stato abbandonato e
stava cadendo in disuso.
Molto importante è l'ultimo aspetto,
che è più legato alla governance
e alla gestione.
L'economia e il processo di
formazione educativa.
La fattoria didattica sta dimostrando che
l'aula, come setting, è importante ma
è importante anche una
formazione esperienziale:
il bambino deve
"mettere le mani in pasta",
deve utilizzare i sensi al meglio
e all'interno di questa realtà,
scopriamo tristemente purtroppo che
spesso l'aderenza alla realtà si interrope
fin troppo presto
nel processo di vita di una persona,
tant'è che i bambini
non riconoscono la carota,
domandano se l'uovo cresce
dall'albero piuttosto che
di vedere la mucca viola. Ecco.
Quindi attraverso le semplici visite che
si possono fare nelle aziende agricole
viene recuperata proprio l'aderenza
alla realtà:
da dove viene quello che mangiamo.
L'economia sociale è il movimento,
diciamo così, economico
al quale aderiamo.
Economia sociale è quella dell'impresa
senza scopo di lucro,
che non significa che non deve
raggiungere l'equilibrio aziendale
ma che non divide gli utili
alla fine dell'anno,
quindi non c'è una massimizzazione
del capitale
per ottenere degli stipendi stratosferici.
C'è il principio della "porta aperta",
per cui tutti possono presentarsi, e
se l'azienda gode di buona salute
deve tenere in considerazione
le candidature delle persone
che si fanno avanti.
C'è il principio di una testa con voto,
quindi ogni scelta è
fortemente democratica,
e quindi anche in questo senso
l'agricoltura sociale si muove
in una dimensione
di democrazia partecipativa.
Quello che ho pensato di realizzare,
appunto grazie alle esperienze personali,
è stata la semente.
La semente che parte con un centro diurno,
dove 12 ragazzi autistici attualmente
nella campagna di Spello
stanno affrontando un
percorso riabilitativo,
che punta da una parte a mantenere
le abilità per un'autonomia personale,
abilità che i ragazzi hanno acquisito
nel corso della propria vita,
all'interno della scuola e all'interno
di altri servizi;
e dall'altra a trasferire abilità
atte a un inserimento lavorativo.
Quindi il focus è il
trasferimento di abilità
per un impiego di qualsiasi tipo,
con qualsiasi contratto,
per qualsiasi monte ore.
Abbiamo laboratori ergo-terapici,
facciamo comunicazione
aumentativa alternativa,
perché queste persone
funzionano diversamente,
e quindi abbiamo un po' abbandonato
il principio della solidarietà,
cioè noi non puntiamo a
rendere tutti uguali,
bensì permettiamo agli
uguali di essere diversi,
siamo fraterni.
Facciamo orticoltura,
quindi abbiamo un pezzetto d'orto,
in cui non si vedono spesso
nascere gli ortaggi o i fiori
perché appunto ha uno scopo terapeutico;
e facciamo esperienze con animali,
abbiamo galline, abbiamo
alpaca, e altre specie...
Questo è un particolare di un'attività
che è il confezionamento
delle specie che coltiviamo.
C'è poi una parte, uno spinoff,
quindi vengo al secondo modulo,
dalla parte sanitaria passiamo
alla parte commerciale.
Una cooperativa agricola sociale in cui
i ragazzi riabilitati, riavviati
all'interno del centro diurno
possono trovare un lavoro vero.
Per darvi dei dati,
due dei ragazzi che
abbiamo avviato al lavoro
dal 2011 ad oggi, hanno firmato
l'atto costitutivo della cooperativa
che gestisce questa fattoria,
e sono diventati, si sono trasformati da
assistiti in soci lavoratori.
Esonerando anche lo Stato
dalla quota di assistenza,
in termini monetari,
che rivolgeva a queste persone.
C'è una produzione biologica,
facciamo orticoltura, frutta,
ci sono allevamenti,
c'è un agriturismo e un ristorante,
e facciamo percorsi didattici
con le scolaresche.
Qui un particolare delle nostre colture,
che ovviamente sono biologiche.
Terza ed ultima parte.
Abbiamo guardato fuori
dalle nostre finestre,
e abbiamo detto: molto probabilmente
riusciremo a ottenere un bel successo
facendo capire ai nostri vicini
cittadinanza, altre
imprese agricole, eccetera,
che i nostri ragazzi non sono un peso,
ma sono un'opportunità.
E quindi abbiamo ragionato
facendo marketing sociale,
facendo un coinvolgimento,
creando un'associazione
temporanea di scopo
con l'Università degli Studi di Perugia,
il Parco Tecnologico dell'Umbria,
la Confederazione Italiana
degli Agricoltori,
e 5 imprese profit che confinano con noi,
e appunto abbiamo dato vita
a questo distretto in cui
fondamentalmente si sta
insieme e si comunica;
da cosa nasce cose,
abbiamo fatto fiere insieme,
scambiamo i canali commerciali,
e facciamo sperimentazioni
attraverso progettazioni europee.
Questa è un particolare
di uno degli eventi
che realizziamo all'interno del distretto.
Grazie a tutti.